already this year sydney and much of new
south wales have been devastated by
torrential rain and floods the forecast
is more of the same with the latest
state of the environment report
declaring that extreme weather events
like this are becoming the new norm in
the last five years we've documented the
impact of extreme events such as
storms wildfires
and
very large bleaching events caused by
heat waves
cyclones
droughts and floods and they have
impacted almost every square inch of
australia the 2 000 page scientific
document paints a grim picture of
australia's ecosystems from marine
environments to the desert land and
ocean temperatures are on the rise and
australia has lost more mammal species
than any other continent
we name our footy teams
and sporting teams after australian
animals we really love our wildlife in
australia it's so unique to the world
but we are destroying their homes and
the thing we can do to protect them is
to protect their home protect their
habitats the scientific authors say
pollution mining invasive species and
climate change are to blame their
solution is a drastic reduction in
carbon emissions as well as stronger
national environment laws and a federal
regulator to enforce them
the state of the environment report is
compiled every five years the last four
have painted a grim picture but the past
reports have predicted the future
impacts of climate change this latest
scientific assessment is recording the
extensive damage that's happening now
responding to the report australia's
newly elected government announced plans
to protect 30 of the country's land and
oceans by 2030.
what the environment really needs is a
changed system
that's the message from the samuel
review
that's the message from the state of the
environment report
without structural change we'll be
resigning ourselves to another decade of
failure
without the tools we need to arrest our
decline
another decade scientists say is too
late
sarah clark al jazeera brisbane
australia